you know when you get a Feeling
I'm doing this 20 years I've never had a
feeling like this you're gonna see
exactly what I see this is what
greatness I need the greatest basketball
shoe that's ever been made what's the
plan we build a shoe line around just
him for a rookie who's never set foot on
an NBA court who's the player Michael
Jordan
we can't get Michael Jordan I'm thinking
of reaching out to the parents you talk
directly to the family you're going to
lose your job do you typically show up
at people's front doors unannounced I
was told not to call oh man here we go
every once in a while someone comes
along that's so extraordinary that it
forces change because they are so very
special a shoe is just a shoe until my
son steps into it
air weighted R exclusive in theaters
April 5th